[Music]
what's up daily be obviously trying and
continuing to innovate and doing some
fun stuff what you're being what you're
about to see is a merged dailyvee Dallas
and Atlanta to talks double the fun
three talks that's right - two in Dallas
Thank You drug you'll probably see the
rock watching you behind the camera
right you won't see the rock which is
just how I like it hope you enjoy this
you got your perspective hello how are
you sir good my right ear please
Dallas Texas
we're here at the national radio
conference but their term radio is being
Loosli at this event you know podcasting
boys
I genuinely think the ears or the next
game I have been talking about that for
a while as well in fact we're recording
to some video and I'm not so sold that
more people will consume this through
just audio than in video form so I'm
excited to be here it is a you got it it
is a classic thank you so much it's a
classic audience I'd you know I think
the far majority people here are from
the hardcore radio industry and so the
challenge here
how do you you know a lot of industries
are genuine genuine trouble if they
don't have a hard pivot this industry
has to take a soft pivot
because the macro thesis is gonna be
okay in fact they're about to go into a
golden era however if they become
romantic about how that content is being
distributed they can be common quite
vulnerable and not as successful if
they're romantic that has to be done
unserious we're on 7 7 a.m. or and not
as a skill or a briefing on a lecture
Google home or not as a podcast or not
as video being filmed while that radio
show is going on
lose
winning is better than losing I'm gonna
try to land it thank you so much you're
comfortable buddy count to ten for me
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one
when your tongue one two three four five
six seven nine ten no eight you good I'm
good
abcdefg hijk LMNOP
thank you
winning is better than losing thank you
you know thank you I think I think
finding the right balance of that what
you just said is we have so much empathy
gratitude towards any partner we work
with while they'll know whatever we need
to do from a time standpoint or things
that miss magic are you met so Yankees
like this is funny so I'm a die-hard
sports fan like the fact you brought up
the fan just said made me smile in my
heart we should come over what are the
highlights of boomer and all those guys
might love all those guys
[Music]
grew up a humungous for sports sports
fan was born in the Soviet Union
Kant grew up in Jersey so had a real mix
so I was a Jets Yankees Rangers Knicks
fan but the Rangers and Yankees I
literally stopped watching completely
the day they won the championships in 94
96 I like completely missed the Yankees
dynasty because I got 96 Charlie Hayes
catches the ball and I literally do not
watch another Yankees game anyway it's
the wildest thing I'm now please don't
turn your back on radio because it means
so much do you know do you know how
historically on board with radio I've
been over the rest of it I'm I believe
in audio more because I know you always
talk about it you're my my love my
number one thing here is gonna be as
long as you're not overly emotional in
the pipes that distribute it they will
be unbelievably fine you will actually
go into the next golden era if you are
disproportionately vested in the actual
pipes and are caught in that you need to
start creating the other pipes because
if you put in your head in the sand on
the pipes you will get destroyed javis
that's the truth your abs there's no
reason that that most of the companies
in there that have not started whether
it's Alexa whether it's podcasting
whether it's something else why let's
some other entrepreneur come along and
take that oh you're dead right
you go but do me a favor yes you ever
want to I'll reach out to you and at
least if you want to stop I and I will
with those guys I'll be great I'm happy
to do it love to possum take care all
right any business here that digs in its
heels and thinks the traditional
distribution of radio is going to win
out the game in the next decade is going
to lose the Internet will continue to
eat up market share it will happen and
when it happens the important part is to
make sure you are diverse if you're in
the distribution business across
building briefings and skills across the
voice devices that will dominate the
homes and the behavior and the offices
and the cars of all of our consumers and
podcasts will continue to grow and
people listening to audio through video
products will continue to grow and if
you happen to be in the content business
in here well get ready to get rich
because if you have the best content
over this half century it's going to
work out it's as simple as that the art
is now winning the business leverage
game not the pipes because the pipe came
along that changed the course of the
industry it's called the Internet we
continue for me down in this room to
wildly underestimate the Internet let me
remind you of how young the platform
actually is the consumer web not the
nerd stuff that the military and
academia was doing the consumer web is a
1994 1996-1998 phenomenon we are just
getting started and the indicators are
in the water the one thing I don't
understand is macroeconomics what I can
tell you is that if Jeff Bezos is the
CEO of Amazon and the macro economy is
in a good place
it's the lay-up of all time because he's
100% consumer centric and playing for
his legacy which means his behavior will
play out well long term 99% of Fortune
500 companies are run by executives who
care about what the stock price will be
when she or he retires six months later
so they can strike and buy a yacht those
companies lose so that's my stock
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thanks for saying
that
I'm so happy to be here with you guys
thank you my friend thank you for saying
that
thank you who's taking this we should I
give this to be appreciated render see
lucky wear t-shirts
thank you thank you so much
[Music]
all right yes my picture became you you
are one of my most wait I got you more
the reason why I don't give a [ __ ] what
that means you're welcome so much thank
you for seeing us of therapy I'm glad
you didn't you thank you thank you thank
you yes I'm on WFAN you changed my life
too because thanks a what I think good
friend Oh made me go up in the rating
system that makes me happy you're doing
well take care
[ __ ] sorry thank you for saying that
you're welcome thank you so much thank
you for that take care made sense right
mix this for you a quick thank you I got
my first job by citing your book in my
interview and they were very pressed
that I'd be aware what I was doing that
means a lot to me yeah thank you big fan
thank you love to get a picture sure
have some questions but I'm not even
gonna fire away while we take tip fire
one away while we're doing this what
would you say about people who work in
those goliaths who are trying to get the
fridge and just aren't being heard put
it on the table respectfully so you
don't get fired but you're historically
correct so that when people leave or
when things get bad they're like wait a
minute
Roy was right let's make him a VP at
this new thing you can't you're not
gonna change a Goliath but the people
that don't die on their own sword don't
move up either so if you believe it's a
it's no different than what you did to
get the job yeah take care of it
thank you guys bye-bye thank you thank
you yes you a question yes sir
I mean experimenting with the content
and the reason why there's so much to do
and in the way because that's a but
that's a good thing yeah it'd be much
it'd be way worse if there was nothing
to do yeah don't get crippled don't get
crippled by opportunity don't judge
yourself that's what will help yeah so
what you're about to listen to is are we
going here oh yeah okay all right so I
think you just changed the definition
for radio for this audience today in a
big way what do we need
the definition of radio for advertisers
you know I think one week if we're not
romantic about the word radio then we
can get into a conversation of voice
content delivering value to the end
consumer and we need to for brands and
businesses make them think of us as that
not as the thing they grew up with that
is on the dial of the car or in their
home and so the the the network's need
to make themselves 360 and not just be
at the mercy of one distribution they
need to be in the podcast business they
need to be in the audio skills business
they need to be in the video business
every single radio show in America
should be filming it and putting each
episode on YouTube and Facebook and
LinkedIn today many of them are many are
but you touch the many most aren't right
99% are not or they don't think they
have to write they subconsciously even
forget about consciously subconsciously
get into a romantic point of view of
like this will be okay
we've always been around we'll be okay
audio is more than okay I actually think
audio this biggest era probably since
radios hit the scene is on the verge of
being here it's the it's the way that
audio is being distributed that I think
needs to have a thoughtful conversation
so to talk about audio content for a
second yes I mean what makes it
incredibly relevant era
engaging the consumer and there's a part
two tips so radio and the former
definition is a collection of incredibly
powerful brands yes right and those
brands employ incredibly powerful human
beings yes that create content yes life
and those and those brands are at the
mercy of the casting of those human
beings no different than a sports team
or a company right right keep going
right so what do they need to do to
continue to remain relevant and engaging
in this new audio content well who the
the radio station brands let's start
there let's start there if you're a
radio station right if you're z100 in
its apex in nineteen ninety three
nineteen eighty eight two thousand
whenever the apex is if you didn't start
building brand on the internet in 2000
and definitely in this audio explosion
if the z100 I'm just gonna use it
because I grew up in Jersey
if the z100 is not a relevant player in
podcast land if z100 doesn't have a very
thoughtful voice activated divisive
strategy of how it's gonna show up
uniquely on a lexer google home or apple
pod or whatever else if z100 is not
putting out its video clips on Facebook
YouTube Instagram tick-tock and and if
z100 is not a podcast brand that matters
z100 is vulnerable right that's budget
needs to be very big 100 percent and
this is and it's funny you say this this
is my biggest point and you know we're
walking you're watching it manifest well
I I'm living it I I am building brand
and a speed and at a scale that is
unusual and if you've taken to account
that I am NOT on a television show it's
unparalleled and it's completely based
on this thesis which makes it fun for me
to talk because I'm not hypothesizing
here I'm living it
right so you're an audiophile right I
believe in audio the most because I like
every human that's watching me and
listening right now is now a creature of
20/20 and wants to do multiple things
you know we're amazed by our kids
ability to be on the iPad the iPhone and
watch TV we did it too you watched MTV
while you while you were on a two-way
phone call with your friend and going
through a teeny bopper magazine you
multitask - that's what humans do radio
matters because radio matters because it
is one of the distribution tools for
audio content and audio content is
massively on the rise in our society
because humans want to multitask in a
2020 world and radio works because same
answer radio works when the audio
content is consumed and the creative
coming out of the human's mouth
influences the person on the other side
and to do the transaction that the
company wants whether that's to buy a
sneaker or to go to a concert it audio
much like what I'm doing right now is a
form of communication that has the
ability to change one's mind and that's
always powerful but because I role the
way I roll the conversation is not audio
the conversation is you're using the
literal interpretation of radio you may
be using it under the context of all
distribution you may most people do it
you may I don't know and that's fine
honestly I have no vested interest or
even passion one way or the other but
but I would not want to be a linear
network today I do not want to be CBS
NBC and ABC in 2020 selling Empire I
want to be an OTT or YouTube that's just
the reality of what consumers are doing
and this is historic by the way
everybody's listening or watching go do
your history lesson of what happened
when the radio came out - the newspaper
industry or when the television came out
- the radio industry or when cable came
to the 13 channels or when the internet
came to cable or when the OTT I mean
this is
forever this will be forever people used
to do smoke signals on balance that's
how we taught people used to draw in
caves that was real that is how we sold
things change and we need to change with
them
pictures and video and words and audio
that will never change that's how we
communicate where we communicate it and
in what distribution form is constantly
changing some things get 50 years some
things get 3 minutes the Internet's
gonna get a long time my sweets didn't
have the longest time vine didn't have
the longest time tick tock may or may
not it may be Facebook and YouTube it
may not but at the moment if you want to
sell something to a 15 year old in
America tick tock is the place you need
to put your energy that's just real life
thank you thank you so much thank you
thank you I appreciate it
awesome thank you yep you got it really
nice to meet you take care sir bye guys
bye everyone bye guys
take care take care thank you that was
great I think that was a I think that
really resonated with the room if I mean
it and I couldn't push you guys harder
to do that you gotta aim you know the
problem the problem in this industry is
people are so romantically attached the
end
that's it good love it that's it people
dig in right that's why people lose
people dig in I mean it's it's they dig
in on something they don't even realize
why they're digging in
you know the diggin in because nostalgia
is a very powerful part of our framework
it's Rangers on home flight away it's
gonna take me time though I'm gonna do
it
what do you live I know it very well I I
do so much garage saleing in New Jersey
so I know like every cent I did a lot of
direct mail so I understand I think yeah
it really was
really really yeah was I I nailed the
ending if we just like kind of like
relaxing hey guys we're about to listen
to is a really you know it's really
funny I'm doing a central right now just
after D Rock and I spoke for a minute of
like how good that one felt speaking to
the radio and audio industry I'm always
that kind of quote unquote I think I'm
at my best when I'm at a conference
where that industry's timing is at a
crossroads where if they give up on
romance and focus on their ability to
actually leverage what they're doing
right now and not allow new incumbent
distributors of the energy whether
that's retail or media they can win and
I feel I feel very obligated when I
speak to bring the most value and I feel
I brought a lot of value today this
morning here in Dallas I hope you enjoy
this podcast
people say to me like what is the
greatest piece of advice you ever
received
I said was that moment when I was at
Milo's do you remember that I remember
it like yesterday
of course Gary was the man you said stop
focusing on the [ __ ] that you suck at
and double down on your strings get it
where brother I'm so happy for you man
that makes me so happy I get a good job
a hundred percent thank you thank you I
got it down take care guys where's the
LinkedIn thing want to go on stage this
is no no it otherwise I will take you
through the back and we'll do a walk out
it's gonna be a lot of people huh it's
4,500 loving Nisan back here and then
you're on stage 3:45 I'm very happy
thank you Andy Brock what's what happens
then I go back to the hotel right you
sure cuz that's all we did yo what a do
this is what your dream water fades oh
it happened to see hey guys yve what up
okay oh they go dear oh dear oh dear I
you know dream dream motivate let me
tell you something back Gary man if
you're not following him you need to
follow he lost your mind
Pinot grig written books he is awesome
motivator and he doesn't like being
caught motivational speaker however he
is a very good businessman and we got to
like he just shares from now license
cami Alyssa North Quarter listen it
comes down to this we got one at bat
right like nobody's come back from the
dead you can't prove it
you got one at bat and I don't
understand why people live in their
lives based on other people's opinions
your mama your boss a comment in
Instagram like focus on you like offense
that is so amazing let me
kind of tell you I'm tripping right now
like I'm trembling I look at you know
she smell good by the way on the record
smell benefit yeah and I've been looking
at the garage sale yes deflatinator the
flipping I'm looking at all your posts
I've seen the growth I've seen you know
you had the Jets game a secret I listen
I'm telling you ask me a question I tell
you about yourself there's no but I'll
follow you I'm humbled I'm a kid from
the hood never had nothing I started my
marketing firm just being trying to
Kinnick trying to grind trying to get an
opportunity I begin I call it the
Heisman you know the Heisman you go wow
uh-huh instead of bringing you in I mean
look look look look right now I'm taking
a listen right now I'm taking some heat
from people about free work is a good
idea and people like oh that's bad
you're mean I'm like you're saying that
from a place of privilege like you know
people come up and when people are
Heisman one of the ways to break that
stiff arm is like oh you don't think I
can do it let me do it for free for a
week you do it three four years like
people are get it when the door when the
door is not open free is the [ __ ] key
yes yes and because we've got to show
people your worth and I click like right
people like these people like when you
don't do that you're not valuing your
worth but the reality is you need
context and by the way if you say hey
Jeremy I'll do it for you for free or
hey Nike I'll do for you key rock or
LinkedIn you can stop at any moment you
can stop the first day after free if
you're like oh wait a minute ear ox dick
no you don't have a monumental you are
now I'm not trying to you know jus be
like trying to get you a new another new
I'm saying is I've been an entrepreneur
right you like made an entrepreneur like
a verb like you like made it cool like
you made it swagger and you say it out
of time but a lot of people you give
away so much game that's that's like you
that's where I was going you give my
game and you know that you know
hopefully the reciprocity because
because because funny it's not hopefully
the reciprocity comes it's that it's
that what I'm feeling right now
admiration is more interesting to me
than an extra zero in my bank account
it's not complicated it's not super
complicated I know that most people
don't talk about it
but it's not complicated some people
like admiration and legacy more than
money I I remember you said something I
was like man I've never thought about
things like you know what I want to do I
want to have the biggest funeral ever
yeah I didn't feel quite an admiration
like who are you who were you and if you
pass away our people shall we're not
gonna die if you pass away and there's
four crickets
yeah and your mom and you can and you're
going if you want go into the ground
with 12 million dollars and four people
are at your funeral you [ __ ] lost yes
man and that shook that shook me that
means like every person I see I'm gonna
smile in my behind a bad day I'm gonna
tell you like yo man you smell good like
just like you're having it's true and
I'm just saying this the Bible says you
have nothing and that's I know you have
you from the hill but you have not
because you ask not
I will come in if you need some full
working down easy or come out there to
New York I would let it come to the to
the spot I'll fly off I'm gonna have you
do you recollect right now cuz I gotta
go through my say hello to a couple
people but that's done live your life
yours hey can I get a tag a dream
motivates game cook but keep listening
to dream motivates cuz he smells good
all gems ears yeah they love you they
want know why you like gen Z if you can
hold on you got it I got garyvee in the
house why do you like to envy gens e my
like Gen Z because they're gonna be
around the longest from all the other
generations that are here it's cuz I
like like the kids are always right
people just don't know when at first I
agreed okay I need a text I listen to
these guys to learn more about Gen Z the
guys it scary to be listen to these guys
to learn more about Gen Z okay thank you
thanks for having the books from God we
ran into
you'll get his email you're amazing I
always love watching your crab thank you
thank you thank you so much what's your
name - Lily Lily yes hi who are you
I reckon LinkedIn I'm a hustling
musician on the side as well awesome
Thank You social for you guys it's just
you know the stuff I say is what I
believe I think it's a game of patience
I think where youngsters get caught is
you don't realize how little time the
next five years actually is but the
distressing five years it's two years
people worried about two weeks right
nope and that's because people worry
about that's how I got into judgment the
real reason you're worried about that is
because you actually care what other
people think
yeah and so people just live in their
lives based on other people and I told
ways a bad idea it's called defense in
by nature it's called defense you know
what I mean
so nice meeting your shot yeah I didn't
go see these guys to see you listen to
these guys for Gen Z 2009 in this room
yes and as we said it represents in the
world yes and the industry as a whole is
evolving recruitment marketing make a
Content is is growing there's one of the
fastest growing aspects of this industry
make sense and I think a lot of the
questions that I hear are about just
where to start because these are
businesses that haven't traditionally
needed to think about a marketing
strategy a content strategy a brand
strategy
what's this is super funny and obviously
like I think a lot of some some people
here know me or consume me like I've
been screaming for the last year about
LinkedIn like it I'm telling people that
self fitness equipment and raisins and
socks to do content marketing on
LinkedIn you can imagine you can imagine
what I think you should be doing on it
I mean if you are not producing four to
twelve pieces of content a day at the
scale of your businesses here and
probably even closer to 25 on LinkedIn a
day organically you're making a
fundamental mistake and there's nobody
here even remotely close to doing that I
believe that to be true I really believe
it you know I'm glad and I hope you do
because you know I think what you may
know based on jumping in or some of you
may know following my career the last 10
years I end up being write about this
stuff a lot here's why I'm not guessing
this is happening right now like the
organic reach in LinkedIn content right
now is far more reminiscent to 2011 and
12 Facebook than anything I've seen I
would think that you're probably aware
that there was a golden year of Facebook
organic marketing that you heard about
from your friends or you lived or know
of its existence it is happening right
now in your face in LinkedIn which is
the biggest permission for b2b people on
earth ever in the last 20 years to get a
good deal and yet a people aren't acting
on it because be they are not consumer
centric you will not produce content
that brings value to the companies or
trying to serve or the people you will
make content that is a lead gen to your
business and that's why it won't succeed
and that's why the content won't
resonate as much so it's not only
recognizing the strategy but it's
understanding how to make the creative
that actually brings value to the other
person and being disciplined enough to
being able to do that there's no secret
of how to get into better shape eat
better workout but many people can't
keep the regimen for a million different
reasons my strategies are basic it's not
super complicated this is execution
when you're talking about like
reinvesting into your company do you
ever have like an idea or recommendation
that you give to companies in terms of
like how much of a percent of a revenue
they should be reinvesting no to
marketing no no my answer is as much as
humanly possible I believe that the
internet will commoditize everything
except brand as much as humanly possible
like communications the only thing left
the product itself like obviously if
you're candy bar sucks
I'll just speed up everyone knowing it
sucks the product and your brand because
everything in the middle is in trouble
bookstores went burst limos and cars and
went the entire macro infrastructure of
physical retail is happening right now
wait do you see what happens to the fast
food and fast casual space with all
these cloud kitchens and everyone's
ordering everything and getting food
delivered in one minute on brands that
don't have stores but it's the new
McDonald's it hasn't even started you
guys have felt the effects there's been
technology things that nature and
they'll be more I would never I it's
very rare for us to consider to hire an
outside recruiting firm because I'm just
gonna analyze people in the wild the
Dave is there wait to that becomes
consolidated wait to people understand
that is a very good way to do it you
better build a brand because it is
reputation it's why people say all those
things right there right until they're
not and and how you build your
reputation and the scale in which you
can and what's happening and the ability
what's gonna happen and has already
happened to some of you and you know
this to be true is you see this I mean
this is a ridiculously big spider
what's good what's gonna happen is
somebody who's only been in a business
for three years is gonna start winning
business from you and you're gonna be
complaining that they have no experience
of what the hell but they've already
struck the heart in the mind of the
person that decided because they watched
for videos on LinkedIn and they made
sense to them and they're very thrilled
that you've been doing this for 26 years
but Karen made sense to them a week ago
don't let that happen like I said
earlier today in a different conference
which has been a fun day two talks which
is rare for me
Goliath should never lose to David be of
a big company which I assume at some
level you do hear or influence or
what-have-you
you should not be losing top starts none
of those wine stores should have lost
too many they just didn't believe in
email and Google they thought catalogs
were better thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
to pot it up for you okay understood
right
[Music]
read some humongous LinkedIn event
there's like 6,000 people up there
4500 6,000
it's a solid number
I'm feeling Dirac something
and going live in like six seven minutes
at this keynote so if you're catching us
right now check it out this hair
swipe up do you rock what have you
learned today care about your employees
you didn't know that before they learned
it again hit over and over and over
again
but I say it in different ways very
different way in different context yeah
distributed differently on different
platforms with different analogies and
nuances and sometimes a word that
changes it in a way that finally makes
someone see it like today or the person
just ready to see it yeah a little bit
of you need to hear in a different way
sometime or you need in here in multiple
ways and then one day well or something
might have happened today that made you
actually hear it differently right six
thousand five thousand got leg up you
did and I stole your gum I just took
this out of your hands I don't think the
camera
oh and that one boat right here this
incredible moment to be nope and I love
this moment because in seven years I
won't be is underrated like I'll have to
like change act like I'll have to like
what's that TV show like the secret
[ __ ] singers the mast what is this
show that's huge right now the mast the
mast [ __ ]
no we're there like in costumes that are
singing oh you know what I'm talking
about
I feel like I'm gonna do that in 20
years when I feel like I'm gonna get
like a what's that movie with Travolta
and or like [ __ ] thanks Nicolas Cage
okay so I'm literally gonna win it the
whole [ __ ] big and then rip my face
off and come back as a different you
minute and win it again be like say
wasn't luck that's fine I'll be easy
that's easier to rip your [ __ ] face
off
[Applause]
[Music]
pursue her dreams she can always go back
to school
you're welcome
yes sir one dire judge Manju is that you
clapping I saw you bro I saw you but are
you gonna buy the team come soon enough
I need 20 years bro but you're young
you'll get there hey hey hi guys
whatever be
[Music]
I love the background going
[Music]
[Music]
I appreciate that I got your colony
Eli what up bro oh and three don't worry
we're coming back thank you bye guys
[Music]
now somebody some guy Brandon and
Twitter's like bro why'd you interrupt
tilman 42 so much you were interviewing
a billionaire give a [ __ ]
up whether I'm being sweet or being
interruptive or being competitive or
being kind or doing business or doing
friendship I'm gonna [ __ ] about how much
money you have in your bank account it's
the [ __ ] stupidest [ __ ] of all time
judging somebody based on that or really
the best thing of all time and I hate
using stupid a very bad idea
is treating people different because of
their status or financial framework
[Music]
actually I just got motivated I'm
sending a text you know good morning I
just got fired up so I'm sending you
this text here's the tip of the [ __ ]
day treating somebody different because
of their financial status or their
cultural status or how many followers
they have thinking that you treat people
with privilege even if they earned it
even if they [ __ ] earn every part of
it treating somebody different is a huge
mistake I don't think I have that much
time on the text no I don't
yo you know I just got super fired up
somebody said something on Twitter that
triggered me good morning what's up tip
of the day treating somebody differently
because they have money or fame as
Ludacris is Ludacris treat everybody the
same
[ __ ] 5:24 or forties intro
yo what up guys another in depth is this
for the podcast yeah for the podcast
what's up podcast hope your runs going
well hope your dog pooped and you guys
are heading back to the house I hope you
had a good day at work and you're
driving in the car and there's not too
much traffic for nice insight from
September 24th people are learning like
[ __ ] crazy from this I hope you enjoy
it you should sign up for a four DS it
is absolutely the Sasha group the Sasha
group calm vaynermedia's Feiner access
agency for small businesses it is
absolutely the number one thing we sell
in the world that has been most loved
anyway nonetheless here's an insight to
one of the hours that I spend with
people at 40 s which is one of their 12
hours in that day
[Music]
like we're either gonna finish that were
infected me out like anymore we all kind
never like literally another than last
week it's [ __ ] huge this conference
and then I'm out if you haven't checked
out my text platform to one two nine
three one five seven three one text me
sucka how are you bro good to see you
that's what's up that's what's up
thank you for saying that
[Music]
almost got destroyed by salad just fun
stuff
yes I think I think that yeah you know
like even the part with AJ you know like
you know some kind of that makes a
comment but even if you have the camera
down like sometimes it might just be
funny bout to go speak to these lawyers
in Atlanta about building their brand
and not just trying to get SEO and print
and outdoor television radio as a funnel
a little bit more native to this same
mindset is always pretty just like chill
or focused you know usually the Iraq and
I are talking one second before I go
onstage or I'm gonna give me two minutes
and I'll you know think about the first
line and then I'm off or but it's super
easy for me to go up there I'm just
completely and utterly focused on how do
I bring the most value to the people in
the room I know they're lawyers and I
know it's 20 [ __ ] 19 I got the rest
yeah once in a blue moon just to you
know like right before you know when
they're like Gary Vaynerchuk helped
build his father's business and I'm
backstage and I'm just like okay these
are jewelry store owners let me Oh let
me make this comp to my dad's liquor
store or like you know sometimes I'll do
that yesterday I did it in an HR
conference I said I thought about how
funny was that my dad not to his fault
but you know Russian style this big
thing was the the employees or the
enemies or watch out for them to steal
that was running through my mind that's
how I started it sometime but but other
times I'm like okay make sure you tell
them about tick-tock like first thing be
like I made a lawyer tick tock video and
I come out and I'm like Atlanta what's
good you know the baby and you know and
then I'm gone and I lost a whole you
know so it goes both ways
[Music]
let me make it perfectly clear before we
get into Q&A I have zero point zero
interest in you doing anything that I
talked about this morning you're not my
mother
you're not my brother I genuinely don't
give a [ __ ] about you I am doing this
keynote because it's being filmed and I
want to be historically correct and I
will re-air it in eight years when I'm
talking about something else and if you
follow me on Instagram I've quite
enjoyed the last year of pulling up my
videos from 8 and 9 and 7 and 12 years
ago because I'm looking to build my
reputation if you want to go back home
and do exactly what you're doing
I actually am happy about that because
the less money that you put into these
systems is making the bad attention a
better deal for me so so there's no
confusion I prefer you don't do anything
I'm talking about this morning and the
good news for me for doing this for the
last decade is I know that 98% of you
will not I will do a nice job here for
the next 44 minutes we will get fired up
a lot of things are gonna make sense to
you in its mix of cursing and comedy I
will answer very direct questions that
show you I have deep practitioner ship
in this this is in [ __ ] college up
here this is everyday real life I've
built two businesses from scratch one
from scratch excuse me to a 200 million
dollar business over the last nine years
in revenue profitable not valuation I
built a three million dollar business
doing three hundred thousand dollars in
gross profit before expenses with no
credit line and no venture back money to
a sixty million dollar business in five
years as a 22 year old
I'm Mariano Rivera and if you don't know
what that means
Mariano Rivera is a Hall of Fame picture
that just retired and went to the Hall
of Fame recently played for the New York
Yankees he was an extremely good pitcher
he was their closer for two decades but
ultimately if you're a hardcore baseball
knowledgable fan he had one pitch he had
one pitch that literally not one human
being
besides Edgar Martinez knew how to hit
and that's me I suck at a lot of things
the one thing I don't suck at is
understanding what the consumer is doing
at this second I understand human
behavior and I understand human
attention and I understand that not like
buying a mutual fund I understand it
like day trading I know exactly what's
happening right this second on LinkedIn
on tick tock on Facebook on Twitter on
YouTube in print magazines on the radio
in billboards on TV a Netflix period end
of story and that currency is going to
be the single most important thing in
perpetuity because as the Internet
continues to evolve everything in the
middle is commoditized the amount of
people that give a [ __ ] of what college
you went to or how many years of
experience you have is staggeringly low
knowing who you are is super duper
important I'm gonna miss my flight if I
don't back out hello
[Music]
but it's it's a consumer centric
selfless communication structure not a
how do I see it
selfish communication structures and so
it's simple it's inherently not human
most people are deeply insecure and
selfish thus everything manifest from
that but you have to have it seen yeah
you know you could be the sweetest
[ __ ] pumpkin pie of all time if
nobody knows it exists you're [ __ ]
finished and so and even scarier people
are invested in things that seem to be
working because they're used to it and
they're watching it decline by 5 or 7 or
13 or 9 or 11 percent each year and it
just be you know it becomes defense
right you know while I'm not recognizing
your direct mail is just not as good of
a deal as it used to be you know it's
that and then it's Google and then and
my life and then it's not doing it right
you know there's plenty people need to
spend $5,000 on Facebook and have
nothing happen and then they just give
up it doesn't mean that Facebook's
broken you know so those cut there's a
lot of you're absolutely right and it's
an acceptance into simplicity but in the
nuance that I just ranted on that's
where the actually action is because I'm
not special a lot you clearly understand
give to be like you understand the
thesis
it's the filter and the execution
underneath it that is very nuanced
you're never gonna go when you go we're
gonna spend 30 thousand a month with
business agencies help us with our
Facebook's that's right I think in a
small scale in-house is a great way to
go I do just I even think you can steal
somebody my belief is that everybody I'm
looking at right now should take the
at-bat to try to figure it out
themselves because it's that important
that was a point I made about balancing
your checkbook like to me communications
is oxygen no different than actually
understanding how to handle cash flow I
really believe that I believe it's
become that and singularly important I
really believe that I understand that I
understand and honestly I think makes a
ton of sense I mean listen I know how I
never when I hit the business scene
outside of the wine scene I remember
just being very comfortable thank God
again good parenting good circumstances
I feel comfortable being myself
I mean 95% of the comments I got in year
one and two were you don't dress the
part and you curse no one will ever take
you serious and I remember thinking very
early on I'm like what naivete that
results in the end and the consumer will
always make the decision and we value
the things in the middle because we're
taught to school and many other things
we value the middle and the middle is a
commodity everybody's doing the middle
[Music]
do we want it do you guys want to get
food and I'll I'll set up a chair there
everyone sit we'll just go right
hardcore into it let's do it
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to uh I'm gonna
try to maximize value here so I've got
to go to the other room and then catch a
flight so the next 15 minutes or so I'd
love to do more Q&A I'd love people to
get very specific about their questions
and I appreciate you being here and I
hope you enjoyed the talk this morning
let's fire away sir can we close the
door yes fully that well I spent I spend
I spend 100% of my time I'm watching
people react to things not to the actual
thing 100% but I also and what Dirac
would tell you is you know my copy skill
like I know what people want because I'm
listening first for all my talking and
all my interrupting the question and all
this I'm listening at all times thus I
have a better sense I just know what
resonates because I'm so and don't
forget and you know this this is now
[ __ ] 37 years of like I don't you
know this is this is talent you know
like I've had to come to realize I'm
like alright in business in
entrepreneurship and communication no
different than than singing and in
sports there is natural talent the
reason I set up the conversation around
lemonade and baseball cards I've been
doing this for so long it's why I was
such an atrocious student it was so
black and white to me that I couldn't
even give I couldn't even pander to
societal norms of the 80s to even
appease my poor mother who would punish
me so bad every report card because I
wanted that every second in the
classroom to figure out why did they
laugh when I disrupted that why is
everybody wearing those sneak I mean
like it's cry I literally just said
something that I've never said nobody
rocks never heard this Isis sit in class
and
mentally analyzed everything people wore
without even knowing why I was doing
that and so that's it I spend note I
spend notes active I'm a little bit
unusual and you may note I think you
know this I have a separate business
that doesn't monetize my audience thus I
spend no time my great secret compared
to all the other personalities is is
none of the important finances cover 0 0
because the frameworks already been
created I I just know there's some
trickle-down but 0 thought into it I
don't know you know it's just not the
way I think I build other businesses to
make sure I don't have to rely on any
conversion from it hi
you can ask you it when we sell a
t-shirt for fun to learn like I'll do on
my text messaging platform or if it's
those sneakers or the wine i weirdly
like better when it doesn't do well yes
yes but but again the economics are so
my newton compare sale yes which but
really that [ __ ] matters that changes
the entire intent paradigm
okay like a nick saban like brand good I
believe I believe you yeah if you if you
buy taking 20 to 40% of that money and
putting it 100% into something like
Facebook against your core demo fit you
know 45 to 90 that still translates
there and then by teaming up with your
team and others to take 5% and start the
beginning of that next generation which
is not gonna come you are not going to
do well at first or maybe even at all on
Instagram at first but it's just
starting to build the awareness but I
will promise you this sir and this is
universal
there is no radio and billboard perfect
execution that Trump's perfect Facebook
execution for who you're trying to reach
here's why on common sense that
billboard is vanilla the fact that you
can make a reference to jaylen Hertz
transferring to Oklahoma to Oklahoma you
know that you could do all sorts of [ __ ]
you can make 8,000 billboards that
matter to 8,000 different psychographic
and demographic Alabama's got a lot of
micro personalities genders races age
groups you're gonna make it you know why
the Andy Warhol Superbowl commercial
last year that Burger King did missed
the mark because nobody under 40 [ __ ]
knew what the [ __ ] was going on when you
sell vanilla then that was a popular
flavor but when you sell vanilla you
miss a lot of customers and what you're
doing is sheer penetration and you're no
dummy
billboards can't work as well as they
did 10 years ago
every passengers looking down at their
phone I'd rather them see your pretty
face I promised you Seth I'll sneak in
yours too digger
I failed all my classes cuz I do not
listen to Authority I would run Facebook
and LinkedIn ads and make contextual
creative to the data that shows me who
the historic customers you tend to get
are and I would run the ads against
those demographics and psychographics
and I would make 43 different pieces of
video starting you or somebody else that
went to bring them value so that we
built awareness are you [ __ ] crazy
do you know how bad your traditional TV
ad is no matter how awesome you are okay
by building a brand bigger they are in
the only way you if that gets to the
scale that it could listen to the words
if that gets to the scale that it could
in 15 years the only thing that's left
is brand they have to say Alexa get me
can you get me digger
you know they because if they say give
me a personal you know give me a lawyer
give me or whatever of trainer a
milkshake whatever they're going they're
gonna have and that is going to play out
sure
Alexa give me digger you got it yes
ma'am one more I got to finish with
ladies good you love them because it
motivates you or you love them because
you're empathetic to them good so Europe
you're you're a believer that all
polistes good publicity I think that's
fair go ahead it's a great question yes
there is no formula I think your action
I actually think you've got it down
because I do the same I just think it's
comes down to timing and serendipity
sometimes you just got 15 minutes and
you know you're sometimes when there's
something when there's a lot of things
going bad around me I've got some fires
I got some issues my grandma passed away
last you know this last summer and you
know when she was not you know like what
life life right the Jets are only three
I'm on tilt you know you know sometimes
I'm not just in the mood to know I'm
gonna have to spend 15 minutes maybe
going back and forth to try it out right
other times I'm bored feel fresh I got
eight minutes because something got
canceled and I'm like I'm gonna get in
there I wouldn't over judge yourself
there is no proper answer
I think it's predicated on your current
mindset to be able to be the bigger
person people lose because they go into
a debate or a conversation but they're
not emotionally balanced which allows
them to get triggered which makes them
overreact which changes the context of
the actual merit of the conversation
which [ __ ] up the whole thing
aka America welcome
thank you guys thank you thank you so
much new year it's hard it's hard to not
be grateful no no it's actually quite
easy believe it or not you know what I
mean yeah like how can you be I could
how could one be confused that like how
nice it feels you know to take this for
granted would be ludicrous yeah take
care have a great show okay T Rock he
said this must be exhausting I said to
get confused to be grateful and get
confused to take this for granted would
be ludicrous
it was interesting just from 69 you're
luckier than me you got to see it I've
never heard of you before it's a
pleasure to me today is the first day
I'm glad your name Larry Kramer Larry
real pleasure thank you thank you is a
little bit more of the how-to as opposed
to the walk how to super simple the
how-to is Google like I'm I wish it on
Google
correct if you said how do I post a
video on YouTube how does a lawyer where
you based New York Long Island how does
a water Long Island reach got like
Google will answer it the how-to is the
commodity people focus way too much on
the how to the how to you literally go
to Google and any question you can think
of that you would want to ask me right
now whether in written form in a free
white paper or in video form depending
on how you learn you will know how to do
it in three minutes
okay that is the commodity my friend
okay that is the commodity you can find
that and I was looking for social media
marketing people online and it was very
difficult to ferret out I don't know
yeah I mean III think that it's so
important that you should spend three to
five hours googling how to opening the
accounts taking a photo running against
people that live in has them you know
okay and making a video and saying if
you've had an injury ride or whatever
you think is right and learn it's it is
as important as running your P&L it has
become that important
I really believe that I suffered through
that Monday night game I'm the traffic
oh my god yes that was tough
take care Larry how are you good how are
you good thank you so much take care
picker he rock did you get that part too
that that was really good the how to
miss the aggression yeah nobody produce
keep no idea I'm fight Michaels they're
very nice but to be honest I know the
guys the guy the guy the [ __ ] guy
nothing you've been amazing
let's grab our bags
[Music]
[Applause]